[Music]
about to get started
so I hope you enjoyed the keynote
amazing stuff right and I really
appreciate it and welcome you to our
session here where we're gonna be
talking about how ways takes their
approach to monitoring planet-scale
service with a relatively small team how
they do it which tools they use and
what's the approach they've taken before
we get started I like just to introduce
ourselves so my name is Amir Harmelin
and I'm a product manager on Google
cloud with me are two ways there's who
actually do the work that we'll talk
about you need Gruber Hasani and Evgeny
Angelo and they'll be telling about
their experiences monitoring ways so how
many of you don't know what ways is
excellent nobody okay so everyone knows
that's great that's great and I hope you
all use it and so you know how how big
the service is and how how people have
become to depend on ways to get them
where they're going and they depend on
it to be reliable and up and up and
available but we'll take you behind the
scenes so you can understand the
complexity of monitoring and managing
such a huge service so how the service
is built how its deployed what kind of
issues users can run into and what kind
of issues the services itself can
encounter and then we'll talk about ways
'iz approach to taking the data that
they have in and representative
representing it in a in a unified manner
to make it easy to automate their
approach to monitoring and we'll wrap it
up by talking a little a little bit
about the tools they use for monitoring
that are
called stackdriver okay so with that
I'll hand it over to unique thanks Amir
hi everyone I'm unit and I've been a
wizard for the last two years I'm a
devolves DevOps on ways infrastructure
team and let's see a show of hands if
you use a navigation up this week we of
course we all do I do it I use it daily
so for the people who don't know ways
ways is a crowdsource navigation app
it's free and among our best features
are time-saving routes and maps that are
updated daily thanks to our 500,000 a
wonderful volunteer map editors who
updates the maps all the time so we
currently have around 100 million active
users monthly this size of
infrastructure the size of a amount of
users takes a huge infrastructure to
support it so we have thousands of
instances running on hundreds of
auto-scaling groups we have about two
petabytes of Cassandra data running on a
thousand Cassandra instances which makes
us one of the biggest deployments of
Cassandra in the world today this is the
amount of API calls running through our
servers between the different micro
services this is a lot of activity and
it needs a lot of monitoring so we
monitor things that show us the service
level that we give to our users so we
monitor the amount of traffic that's
that query per minute we monitor the
performance of the service that's the
latency and we monitor of course failure
rates so when you have such a big system
and you help people with your driving
downtime is not an option we when an
online game is down people are annoyed I
know when my boys my son's online game
is down he's dead
stated but when Waze is down people get
lost so in some countries in some
countries when they waste is down within
minutes it's in the news in the national
news
that's how essential we are so try to
measure imagine that you are DevOps on
the infrastructure team you're trying to
debug a problem at rush hour
everything is failing and reporters are
calling you to ask details about what's
going on that's a very stressing
situation and we've been there so
downtime is not an option but downtime
happens and I use Waze every day when I
Drive home I want to know how much time
it's going to take me to get to the
school to pick up my kids so I can call
ahead and beg for mercy from the teacher
so we feel responsible to keep our
system online all the time so now that
you understand the size of the challenge
and what we need to monitor and how big
it is let's take a look at the
technology stacks that actually we use a
way so you can see how we carry this
amount of traffic Waze is built on
micro-services we use Java based Java
based a a code we run on standard
instances that are part of an auto
scaling group we use Redis or memcache
as a caching layer and we use Cassandra
or Postgres as the data bases now most
of our services are pretty similar they
look the same but we have a few outliers
some are not Java based and some are not
even running on instances we use as well
kubernetes and App Engine and cloud
functions now these hundreds of micro
services they're talking to each other
sometimes their servers and sometimes
their clients but most of the time they
are both passing data between them with
API calls so to do that we use propriety
communication protocol and this protocol
also collects statistics about these API
calls between the different micro
services and sends them into a central
location so we have a place to pick up
all the statistics about the performance
and usage of these api's our production
critical servers are also split into
dozens of geographical shots now why is
that because it helps to spread the load
between the different areas and it
reduces the impact of bed updates when
we deploy code into production now seems
pretty complicated doesn't it well you
haven't heard the half of it this is
only on one of our logical data centers
I see you split across three regions and
that was only the front end part at the
online part which has the actual user
experience we also have an offline part
which is that which is doing the machine
learning and map building and we use big
data tools to do the post-processing we
use MapReduce and Athena and everything
needs to be monitored oh and double
everything I just said because we use
both GCP and AWS to support deployments
to these two different clouds we are
using spinnaker open source to deploy
our code this gives us an abstraction
layer between the clouds and allows for
seamless management of GCP and AWS so
what we see here in this specific slide
is a simple of a micro service that does
routing you can see on the right hand
that we have 30 and more API calls that
it's using to talk to about five micro
services and on the left side you can
see the scale you can see this is all
this is in one of these rectangle on the
left so you can see the size and the
amount of the API calls this is what
brings us to this staggering number of
25 million API calls per minute on top
of monitoring such a large-scale
infrastructure there are other things to
consider when monitoring we have new
features we have hundreds of engineers
working all the time to extend our
system add new features and deploy new
micro services into production these
needs to be added with monitoring on the
fly without interruption and with zero
config from the developer side there are
hardware failures imagine we have
thousand
of disks running around in the system
and as you all know discs fail this is
something that they do so we need to
monitor that as well
we have quarters when you use a cloud
service
you always get to the 100 percent of
quota usage on any given API at 3 a.m.
in the morning usually so we want to
alert on the 75 percent of the quota
before we get there so we have time to
increase it and request for more because
you all know that takes time as well and
certificates and licenses are also
something that expire within a large
infrastructure so we want to be alerted
three days in advance
so we can request for extension or
replace those certificates with a new
one and of course services hello every
service that we monitor we want to know
the quality of it so we need to know QPM
that's the query per minute failure rate
and latency for the performance and of
course don't forget about the scaling
this whole thing is very dynamic imagine
that we have the geographical shoutings
and each country has a different driving
hours and driving habits and you have
holidays any auto scaling group can grow
from 3 servers up to 120 throughout the
day and shrink back at night you can't
monitor something like that with
configuration files so now that you know
how complicated it is and what are the
challenges can you imagine how to start
deploying a monitoring service on such a
large scale system ladies and gentlemen
I present to you the man behind the
machine he who brought order out of
chaos the Python ninja Evgeny Angelo
[Music]
Thank You Nate hi everybody I'm Morgana
and I'm going to show you how
stackdriver makes sense of our
complicated system that you need just
told you about firstly it wasn't stable
enough and we took us a while to find
out when it was down secondly monitoring
new micro services in our system was
complicated and time-consuming which was
a big problem because new micro services
were being added constantly and we were
having trouble keeping up about two
years ago we heard about new monitoring
system called stackdriver stackdriver
offers powerful tools for collecting and
using time serious metrics we thought it
was pretty cool because it was easier to
see the status of an issue over a long
period of time stackdriver
automatically collects metrics from our
DCP instances and services it can also
import the data from AWS cloud watch
with just a few clicks of a button
thanks to this who hit the ground
running and got tons of useful info
without any effort on our part the
building next metrics was great but we
also needed another type of metrics and
stackdriver
allowed us to send custom metrics with
all info we needed it's a really
flexible system with great functionality
we also found out that using their API
was super easy and the system was very
stable and it could process a large
amount of metrics quickly realized that
we stack driver the sky was the limit
and we started adding new metrics from
all the various corners of our system
for example we started writing metrics
like request rate and latency and gave
them labels according to their cloud
platform region and more so that way you
could see in one metric information from
instances running on both AWS and GCP
after we added all this data into stack
driver we started thinking about how to
put it to good use
first tool we wanted to make it more
easily accessible for us and for our
developers and we did that by using very
bored API to create specific dashboard
for all our critical services they
basically allowed us to display a lot of
useful information both building and
custom in for even any given service in
a single pane of glass second we wanted
to be alerted when specific metrics meet
predefined conditions they accomplish
that we started using alerting API to
create alert policies which basically
allowed us to define one or more
conditions that will trigger an alert
and define how the alert will be
delivered using notification channels
like web hooks that can report a bug
take their own call or trigger our auto
hearing actions which allow our internal
scripts to try and fix the issue before
we wake up the own code over time we
added even more metrics such as failure
rate cache and database layer state
errors and plenty of client-side metrics
we could also use the data that already
existed in style driver to compare our
current state to the state we had last
week or at some other time in the past
this helped us find anomalies and other
irregular activity which had previously
been next to impossible for example
let's assume that we usually have about
10,000 logins per minute in the Bay Area
during peak hour and today that number
is 10 times higher this could point to a
real problem like login we try storm and
we need to be able to see that now let's
talk about automation after a period of
using stackdriver
we thought that a lot of our service
dashboards were very similar so we
thought why not automate their creation
and we did that using a scheduled
process that scans for new services in
our system and automatically creates a
dashboard using predefined templates
without any additional work for
or the developers you have no idea how
much time saved us it also reduced the
time it takes us to find the root cause
of issues and resolve them because all
the dashboards are created using the
same template the scheduled process also
create alerts for new services with
default threshold and notification
channels after a learning period we
adjust them so then they actually notify
the uncle when they are any issues both
dashboard and policies definitions
whether manually automatically created
are saved in the git repo and can be
modified by the developers and any
developer working a new service can add
themselves identification channel in the
back the issue before this service moves
to production everything we just talked
about help our team sleep better at
night with less false positive and
resolve issue fester okay now I'd like
to show you a demo based on an issue we
had in the past that was so soft quickly
and easily thanks to stackdriver alright
so let's say that I'm currently uncle
it's the middle of the night and I just
got a page on my phone I can see that
it's a page about high failure rate for
one of our routing services so I wake up
open my laptop to see more information
about the alert the email we can see a
link to open incidents to our playbook
and the link to the dashboard in the
bottom we can also see the resources
that triggered the alert before I move
on to the dashboard let's do let's let's
look at the configuration of this alert
we can see this it's pretty easy to read
any developer can easily easily modify
the identification channels duration or
threshold if needed the combiner allows
me to choose whether the trigger they
alert if all the conditions are met or
at least one of them in the notification
field we can choose one or more for
example we can see that in the example
we can see that the very earth will send
animal and trigger our web book that
will call Auto healing bot that auto
auto hearing bot with the details of the
incident this is a dashboard that was
linked in the email the problem can be
seen in the server API failure rate
widget now I filter the metrics in the
widget to focus on the specific metric
related to the issue after scrolling
down a bit in the dashboard I see
something interesting in another widget
displaying service dependencies failure
rate and by dependencies I mean all the
services that routing needs to function
properly I see that geocoding has a high
failure rate it started at the exact
same time so I'll go to the geocoding
dashboard and see something weird in the
Cassandra latency widget grid latency
peaked just before our outing issue
started so I connected to our Cassandra
cluster and manually fix the issue
using our Cassandra playbook in the
future this issue won't even wake me up
because we are very close to finishing
our Cassandra Auto healing process that
will fix it automatically so as I just
demonstrated stackdriver
gives great visibility into our system
and helps us resolve issues much faster
than before
okay so we have hundreds of engineers
working all the time on improving and
system adding new micro services and
extending the existing ones before we
had all these automation tools that if
Gani just spoke about all of this was
done manually in the DevOps team so it's
some time and some it's a time in the
progress we just couldn't keep up with
the workload and large parts of the
system were inadequate monitored and you
know some parts were not monitored at
all so let's take a look how it looks
now with all the automation in place
let's say that I'm a developer it weighs
and I just wrote my new cool micro
service and deployed it into the staging
area now I use the Java micro service
framework that all the developers use in
ways and this framework includes our
monitoring modules already written and
it will start working automatically
those modules I'll tell you a little bit
more about these modules as you can see
from the beginning
this will dashboard will be auto
generated and auto deployed into
stackdriver with the stag driver
dashboard API as soon as I deployed my
service and I'll show you each of these
cubes was it's very little so the first
thing that we'll see are the server API
these are the same API is that I've been
talking before for the specific service
that I'm looking at and I will see query
per minute and I'll see several a
failure rate and I'll see also the
latency you can see on the right side in
the right upper cube also server diff
for the API this is the qpm from last
week so we can see a comparison and see
if there's a change in the behavior of
the application the next set of widgets
are the server exceptions now this is
from this formula application log we
collect with those included modules
inside of the Java framework we include
all the errors from the log and we
export them as a graph in the stack
driver so I can see from the same from
the same dashboard how the application
is performing now the client api's is
like what you can is told before these
are the clients there are con
acting to my micro-service so I can see
as well how they are performing also in
the same dashboard for the micro service
so I can see how my service failure is
affecting other service in ways and the
last set here are the dependencies so my
server is connecting to others micro
services and we can see here the qpm the
query per minute we can see the timeouts
and we can see a the errors for
connecting to other services so I can
see from this dashboard if the problem
is actually in my micro service or maybe
it's downstream even different micro
service so I can continue going between
the micro services until I get to the
problem one also we can see here from
those included monitoring modules we can
see that the memcache qpm query per
minute is showing up all the data layer
is also exposed in the same dashboard so
I can see if the specific service is
having a problem with a memcache or with
the Cassandra it's connecting to I can
even see which table is eating up all
the space so this matrix are great but
they're not enough for my particular use
case let's say that my micro services is
also writing and reading from a queue so
I want to see how what is the queue p.m.
of writing messages to the queue now my
my application already exports these
metrics and there are already stack
driver thanks to the included modules
but I want to see it in the default
dashboard so what I need to do is edit
one configuration file from our stack
driver configuration repo which is saved
indeed push it into production and
that's it in a couple of minutes if
Gainey's automation tool will pick up on
the change in git and we'll add that
widgets via that stack driver dashboard
api's into the dashboard that I'm using
as a developer I can also open a new
config file and create a whole new
dashboard only with the metrics that I
want to see when I'm debugging a problem
all these changes and repeating
dashboard structure helps me at 3:00
a.m. to solve production issues I can
tell which table in the Cassandra is
failing I can see exactly what the
problem is from the logs in the same
dashboard
so the problem so instead of just
getting like an alert ways ease down or
the website is down I get an alert
saying service a is failing and in the
dashboard I can see that it's failing
because of service B which is downstream
a dependency that is not performing well
looking into the future we are using a
spinnaker open source to deploy our
services so now we are starting to
integrate the metrics from stackdriver
into the key enta tool the new key enter
from spinnaker that will take these
metrics and when you're doing a deploy
it will fire up a few instances and do a
comparison of the metrics between the
new instances and the older auto scaling
group to decide if to move forward with
the deployment or to stop and kill those
instances and roll back so this way the
deployment process is automatically
deciding if to continue and no human
intervention is needed this of course
will reduce downtime if AB a deploy is
done so this is me and my League of
Extraordinary Gentlemen we are mostly
DevOps and a few developers and this
tiny DevOps team handles this whole
operation and its uptime we have one on
call for primary issues and one person
who wakes up at night and one secondary
to handle the bugs that the star driver
and a notification channel can open and
where are we today we are sending two
and a half million time series per
minute into stack driver we have
thousands of dashboards all created
automatically through stock driver all
created automatically through stock
driver
dashboard API we have hundreds of
policies all set up on the critical time
series so we know when something is
failing and now I'll hand you back to
Amir who will put everything into
perspective
[Applause]
thank you very much
you need Thank You Afghani yeah so the
next time you use Waze and you're kind
of thinking how does this work keep
working myself and hundreds of millions
of other users now you know the story
this is the team other members are lined
up also if you can recognize them from
the photo so that's the story of how
approach they've taken but let's talk a
little bit about stack driver which is
the platform and collection of services
that they use to enable this monitoring
approach so first of all what you need
and Afghani described is how they use
stag driver we focused mostly around
monitoring so stagger is a platform that
enables you to easily collect metrics
logs another data into a central
repository they take that from open
source components from applications that
are running in Google Cloud or AWS we
use api's and other other methods to
ingest you need did mention the
dashboard API which is currently in
early access
we intend to release it in the future
but it's not available to everyone right
now but the alerting API as well as
other api's mentioned is available and
then you take that data first of all our
stack driver enables you to store it to
maintain it for longer periods and to
create visualizations and insights from
its visualizations in a form of
dashboards inside insights are sometimes
automatically inferred from from the
data and the correlation as well as
generate alerts via our various
notification channels so if Gani
mentioned email and web hook we support
other channels such as pager duty slack
SMS etc and we are expanding our support
for that
and finally stackdriver also supports
other third-party vendor ecosystems so
you can integrate with other tools that
can use the theta and other services in
the cloud one example being taking
logging data and automatically ingesting
it to bigquery for deeper analysis just
to complete the picture stackdriver is
not only about these capabilities we're
building more so we're building context
capabilities and auto inferring of
services we're expanding more of our
visualization technologies adding tools
that can help you better mitigate issues
and deal with incident response etc etc
and you can hear about it in other
lectures as well and just going over the
different stackdriver
products available to you so we mainly
touch the bottom up on monitoring which
you know you can use to visualize an
alert on the health of your application
a stackdriver also has a logging product
that collects your logs in some cases
automatically depending on the service
and lets you analyze them and you know
do fast queries and even do things like
create metrics from logs so you can use
those metrics in dashboards and alerting
policies and other advanced capabilities
we also have error reporting which can
automatically group and detect and alert
you on exceptions and failures in your
code and again the nice thing is that
this suite is tightly integrated so
let's say you already are you already
have logs in the platform then you know
error reporting comes from free you
don't need to instrument another service
you don't need to you know sign up for
for for something else it's
automatically available for you we also
have trays with distributed trays which
we support via API and SDK Zipkin
collectors and it automatically collects
trays and analyzes
your latency for applications running in
app engine debug is another very very
useful tool that lets you debug
applications in production so you can
during production you can insert
breakpoints and logging statements
without all the overhead so you don't
need to instrument it in advance it's a
really cool capability and I hope you
can you're going to see a demo of it in
one of our sessions here and finally
profiler which is an it's actually in
beta and so it's available and it helps
you pinpoint hot spots in your running
you know in our applications running in
the cloud okay so to recap it firstly
how many of you are running services
that you believe our larger scaled in
ways nice which services ok Spotify yeah
that's a huge service that's great love
it I was hoping at least one person
would raise your hand but for the rest
of you this also applies you you know
this approach can also apply to you so
let's recap what we talked about today
right we talked about how large the
largest services and how challenging it
is to monitor it and what are the
implications of not catching errors real
time right what it means to users in the
case of ways it can mean people not you
know reaching their destinations on time
or at all or it can be even you know
sometimes it can even make it to the
news in some countries so downtime is
definitely user pain and the the team
that that is tasked with keeping the
application app it's not a huge team so
you know they neither up an approach
right the system is very dynamic which
creates more challenges so any developer
can add microservices remove micro
services on-the-fly they no need to
check in with this team right and it can
be developers and different floors or in
different buildings so the approach the
team has taken first of all to decide
which
Metrix you know which signals they
collect what they look at in a more
canonical way right for all the micro
services what are we interested in what
metrics watch dashboards what alerting
policies they started there right after
that you know the fine tune because you
know different micro services have you
know different requirements so you can
build and customize and when you have
that kind of canonical approach across
the board built in as much as much
automation as possible so you know the
developers use config files and the
alerting policies and the dashboards and
the metrics that aren't just that
everything is automatically generated to
reduce human error and also to promote
unity so when problems occur engineers
can look at you know different micro
services in the same manner and a
similar pane of glass so automation is a
key part and lastly we talked about the
specific monitoring suite of products
that always uses which is stackdriver
stackdriver is available free to try
just google stackdriver and and get
started just lastly other talks I'm not
gonna go over each one but these are
talks related into monitoring to sre
best practices to how ways in spinnaker
ways uses spinnaker together these are
all great talks we recommend that you
attend them either today or the next
days and don't forget to rate our
session especially if you liked it so
looks like we have a few minutes but we
are
yeah we're standing between you and
lunch with the only worse thing is
standing between you and beer but we are
standing between you and lunch so what
we're gonna do is we're going to wrap it
up here but if you have additional
questions we're gonna just be right here
next to the stage feel free to line up
and come ask us the rest of
enjoy lunch and the rest of the
conference thank you very much thank you
you
[Music]